so I have a boyfriend now his name is
Josh and he's a Christian which is wild
because like I've never dated a
religious person in my life you know so
this is like completely related to me
I'm very flexible if you want me to do
this and this whatever when it comes to
religion because it's important to you
I'm okay with that because it's not that
important yeah I think that's great if
you had to fake it to keep him would you
do that
thank you
[Music]
hi hello welcome to another episode of
big mood my cat's going crazy I was like
can you [ __ ] chill for like one
episode he got it
um good job holy [ __ ] original crew
original
[Applause]
and Austin was the last time yeah
July holy [ __ ]
like the first of July for those of you
who are listening and out watching uh
original crew sound off who's it Tiff
and it's also me Gina and Jess and
Nibbler and Nikki
yeah he's the original crew now
um oh you guys are matching too oh yeah
Nikki and Nibbler yeah yeah
um exactly that's what I said he's
giving us two cents he runs his company
now
God you've ruined my life that explains
it anyways uh hi uh it's good to see you
guys thanks for coming back and joining
us in this episode listen I have it's me
um it's me I like to judge other people
so we're gonna do an episode where we uh
pull everything or we pull threads from
the relationship advice subreddit all
right and uh we're gonna judge other
people because that's what we do this
yeah
every time
yeah yeah I'm just doing it for audio
listening
so I pulled a bunch of threads from the
relationship advice subreddit
um I don't know what's in these topics
I'm gonna be reading it off and [ __ ]
finding out the same time you guys are
all right and we're going to try to give
advice even though we're probably not
the best people but [ __ ] it judging
other people's fun working that's what
we're gonna do so
um I'm okay with giving unsolicited
advice yeah you're pretty good at it if
they take our advice it's on them all
right the first one is overheard my
boyfriend's friend bragging about
messing with his birth or his
girlfriend's birth control pills though
how do I tell her what no no well make
sure she heard the right information
first because what could be the wrong
one like if a guy's just joking around
like like you know if you're a joke if
me and Junior Dragon like poke some
holes in his condom or whatever like
it's just a joke but it's in the uh guy
overhears and goes oh she's poking holes
in your comments bro it's like yeah it
was a joke yeah all right so I'm a 20
year old female uh my boyfriend is 23
year old male uh I'm my boyfriend is
whatever and everyone else is around RH
as well I was at my boyfriend's
apartment this weekend and so were two
of his friends all called him friend one
and friend two all three of them were in
the living room watching TV while I was
sitting in the kitchen which is right
next to the living room there's a wall
separating the tube with uh with this
door-like opening and you can hear
what's happened what happens in the
living room from the kitchen I've been
sitting there for around 30-40 minutes
just scrolling through my phone and
texting a few people here and there the
guys were watching some Sport and
talking loudly they were talking about
all kinds of stuff and I didn't pay much
attention to their conversation out of
nowhere friend one tells my boyfriend
and friend to how he had been messing
around with his girlfriend's pills
friend two asked what pills he was
talking about and friend one said birth
control pills
friend two went on to say dude that's
messed up and my boyfriend said Yeah man
they didn't sound outraged or anything
and it sounded like friends who was
slightly chuckling when he said that and
that was it they were like oh man that's
[ __ ] up yeah and that was it they all
started talking about something
completely different as if nothing
happened while I sat in the room next to
them in disbelief I decided to sit there
for a little bit because I felt like it
would be awkward if I walked by them
right after they uh what just happened
um yeah I heard someone coming towards
the kitchen so I put on my airpods and
pretended that I was busy listening to
something it was friend too getting a
beer out of the fridge and I acted like
I had to take off my airpod to hear what
he was saying I'm in such disbelief and
grossed out I feel like that's a huge
violation I want to tell friend one's
girlfriend but the thing is I'm not
close to her I've met her before when my
boyfriend and I would hang out with them
but we've never exchanged numbers or
follow each other on social media she's
very pretty and seems like a nice person
I want to tell her but I feel like she
you won't believe me I feel like this
will turn into a what is messing with
her pills mean though because like what
if it's just like he wants to try the
sugar pills part because that part's
kind of like oh it really tastes like
sugar I don't know I always think that
uh but I don't I want to know like so he
wants to get her pregnant yeah that's
what that sounds like yeah I feel like
this will turn into a he said she said
situation I doubt she's going to believe
someone who's known for her she's who
she's known for less than a year and met
less than a handful of time over her
long-term boyfriend of many years I'm
kind of paranoid uh and I'm on birth
control as well so for a split second I
did wonder quote do I need to be worried
about my boyfriend and I immediately
felt guilty I know we can be friends
with people who are different from us
and just because a friend does something
doesn't mean uh we do it but we've been
best buddies since high school and I've
heard plenty of stories about their high
school days and how they should always
cover for each other
from what I've been told it was mostly
my my boyfriend covering for friend one
who was basically a [ __ ] boy in high
school my boyfriend explained that he
did that because he was young stupid and
um whatever the bro code uh we all
aren't the same people we were in high
school so I never really cared about
those stories but yeah the thought did
cross my mind for a split second how do
I tell the girlfriend a friend one about
this without having it blow up in my
face how do I make her believe me when I
have zero proof why does she why is she
so worried about her believing her first
of all I would be like look I know you
don't know me and this is gonna sound
really [ __ ] up but I just think you
should know this like as a [ __ ] woman
to woman like I heard them
joking and he was saying that he was
like [ __ ] with your pills yeah like
and you don't have to believe me it's
fine this this is probably going to be
shocking to you I just want you to know
that I did hear that you need to know
this but I think she should also clarify
with the boyfriend like exactly what
what happened in that conversation it's
easy to overhear a conversation and
think you know the pieces of it I don't
know especially she's like kind of kind
of weird in and out yeah exactly and it
just seems kind of a weird thing to
bring up out of nowhere and then like
the two guys are like oh that's [ __ ]
up man and then they move on like I
don't know I just would want to clarify
with my boyfriend like what do you think
your friends say that like he messed
with her his girlfriend's birth control
pills but what but they need cover for
him so she's saying that you can't
really eat that person I just I wouldn't
feel right like saying this definitely
happened when I don't know for sure I
don't know for sure yeah yeah I don't
know for sure like you might need to
know he might be trying to so then trap
you and you can go through him and so
she asked the boyfriend hey did you mess
with my pills and he goes well I was
joking like I said blah blah blah like
no matter which way you go it's like oh
there's someone's gonna cover for it so
at least like make sure you have the
right information first I guess that's
what I that's the boat I would be in I
oh man but like how many ways can one
possibly [ __ ] otherwise you're the
girlfriend that like messed up a weird
friendship that didn't need to be messed
up like
I think I would risk that for someone
who says like oh yeah if someone's
messing with someone yeah absolutely if
that's really what's happening but so I
would just even on the off chance that
it's not happening and I look like a
dumbass like I like because especially
now women can't even get abortions in a
lot of States yeah I'm like I will
[ __ ] I would put my teeth in my mouth
and I don't think guys would discuss
things like that randomly just be like
oh I [ __ ] with my girlfriend's birthday
yeah that's why I think it's kind of
weird like maybe there was a joke on TV
or something like that past them
honestly I think they probably thought
it was awkward and didn't know how to
confirm yeah [ __ ] up that was they
were just like all [ __ ] up they're
like oh man yeah like how do you
confront someone who's doing something
[ __ ] up like that that's your best
homie like yeah that's a risk I'm
willing to take it's like I don't know
if they were joking or not I don't know
but I'm gonna tell you that I keep your
pills locked up I don't know yeah yeah
leave them around where your boyfriend
can touch them
to have to have with the boyfriend like
yeah are you trying to get me pregnant
yeah why that's the that's what I'm
trying to figure out like what's the
benefit is like if he wants a baby with
her and she doesn't want I don't I don't
understand the benefit like I that's why
I would want to make sure that she's
saying like she's so beautiful or
something maybe he feels like he can't
get anyone better so he needs to trap
her somehow mm-hmm yeah I don't know it
just seems like a lot of conjecture
maybe I'm just I'm just playing Devil's
Advocate it just seems like a lot of
like like there's no wise like why
there's no I don't know there's a lot of
gaps in this story I would want to know
like the details of what happened and if
you can't get that from the boyfriend
that I just wouldn't want to make those
assumptions and kind of butt my nose
into someone else's Business Without
Really knowing what they were even
talking about okay so let's uh let's
talk about the other way like what if I
sat here and told you guys like I've
been [ __ ] with Josh's condoms I mean
holes in them I would think you're a
[ __ ] psycho yeah yeah exactly so it's
like I feel like it's equivalent the
other way around you know so it's like I
would probably tell my friend if I like
if I heard like if Jess had a boyfriend
friend and they were like oh yeah I've
been [ __ ] with a birth control I
would run immediately oh well then again
you're like my close friend yeah exactly
so then what if your boyfriend overheard
the conversation and was like hey I
heard you your friends say she poked
holes in her boyfriend's condoms like is
that did she really do that did she
would like if we were sitting around
right like if Steve knew my boyfriend
yeah and we were sitting around and I'm
like yeah I've been poking holes and
caught himself I've been [ __ ] with it
do you think Steve would tell my
boyfriend I don't know I feel like Steve
would have a conversation with you
maybe first first step is go to the
boyfriend like did he really say that
let's see what happens just like what
Nick you're saying I agree with that and
then see how that pans out and if it
pans out in a way where you feel the
need comfortable you need to like your
intuition will tell you if he's [ __ ]
covering [ __ ] can I pull a case in here
oh he's with the baby right now he's
trying to put the baby to sleep oh last
case and be like yeah if you heard me
saying oh yeah I've been [ __ ] with
the condoms I wonder if yeah that's a
good question because Casey's like the
least confrontational person ever yes I
don't know if he would honestly I feel
like he'd probably just
asked me to talk to you yeah or
something like hey wait I just heard
this weird it's really awkward yeah did
I hear right yeah yeah because that's
really [ __ ] up not just like haha
that's [ __ ] up but yeah and then it's
really [ __ ] up if the boyfriend ends
up covering for her though like let's
say she does talk to the boyfriend the
boyfriend she has an intuition feeling
she's covering for the friend I would be
really concerned for my boyfriend yeah
exactly yeah and also I would then
Advance it to speak to the girlfriend at
that point I would even skip the friend
because if my boyfriend's already
covering for him and I feel like he's
good for him obviously the dude's gonna
lie yeah I'm gonna go to the girlfriend
at this point and be like hey I'm
already like not sure about my own
relationship so I have nothing to lose
here you should know that your boyfriend
was joking about this yeah I think
[ __ ] with any sort of birth control
is really yeah absolutely but you know I
would just want to make sure that he was
actually talking about doing that like
really doing that not like a joke and
passing about like oh what if I did this
you know yeah I'd be like for me
personally it's like
I'm [ __ ] up like you know I make
stupid jokes all the time but I have
never
come across a situation where I just
like randomly bring it up yeah like hey
guys I put holes in my condoms but you
wouldn't randomly bring it up like if it
was serious either like yeah you know
like these are really young kids too
they're like 21 to 23 like early early
20s yeah I mean they're just like dumb
frat guys like college guys I don't know
if and probably not not even in a
fraternity just like just that age group
I don't know I don't know if they're
like because what would be the purpose
to get her pregnant is that the purpose
like I I just don't get the context of
like what messing with the pills even
means so I would want to make sure that
like I heard correctly and and what my
boyfriend has to say about that yeah if
the boyfriend's like yeah it's kind of
[ __ ] up but he's doing this then yeah
I'm gonna tell the girl like immediately
but um if the boyfriend's like oh no he
was just like he was being a dumbass and
joking about like whatever was happening
in the commercial then I'm like oh [ __ ]
I yeah oh thank God you know I thought
that you guys were actually messing I
think like nowadays with like guys
there's no guy that would be willing to
like I just want to get this [ __ ]
[ __ ] exactly that's why it's weird to
me yeah especially in that age like yeah
exactly
so
there's a very severely damaged person
yeah who has like crazy attachment
issues
let's say it's off the table I just want
to like yeah just odd it's like
especially before jumping to conclusions
I would kind of just want to really
clarify with the backstory that she
added though about him being a [ __ ] boy
and like yeah but if he's a [ __ ] boy he
wants to stay a [ __ ] boy not a dad but
usually if you like analyze like why
[ __ ] boys are [ __ ] boys because they're
they're really insecure and they have
attachment issues like abandonment
issues like and then maybe he got past
the part of like I want to go cycle
through so many girls now I want to trap
this girl like what if it was just like
how are you gonna keep this girl I was
like I don't [ __ ] with her breast
control bills you know something like
that and they're like oh that's [ __ ]
up bro and then they move on like it's
not a real thing it's just like I don't
know I'm a dumbass I don't know how to
keep her yeah yeah I don't know I I and
look and this is a really
dangerous subject if someone actually is
messing with someone's medication or
birth control pills I just it just seems
like an odd circumstance and I would
just want to make sure that what I heard
was actually what was happening before I
interfered with someone else's
relationship that I have no connection
to yeah
like in my group of friends if I heard
that [ __ ] even if I just heard like the
last few sentences or the last few words
I'm telling someone I'm telling you
because I don't want you to have babies
with this [ __ ] anyways uh top
comment says I wouldn't say this is an
easy conversation but definitely a
necessary one even if he was lying about
messing with her pills I would simply
tell her what you heard and recommend
she check her pills I will tell her that
it's something you only overheard and
wasn't said directly to you wanted to
let you know uh that way it won't blow
up in your face and uh it won't blow up
your face if it's not true either way if
it blows up in your face [ __ ] them all
the responsible thing is uh to tell her
no one needs to surround themselves the
people who are not ethical so the worst
that happens is you find more friends
that have ethics which is true yeah if
you were gonna tell the girlfriend I
would preface it with like hey I'd like
this could be yeah she might have been
something I just yeah completely
misconstrued but yeah you know just in
case I'm just worried about you but also
like what could he be doing because like
if you're taking your pill every day
right like even if you took some of them
out like if you took a short week right
like if it say if I took four pills
instead of five and then continued with
the next week's pill it's like what
could he be doing
to get her pregnant yeah like I don't
know like she knows to take it every day
at [ __ ] noon or something right so
then like what could you possibly do to
them maybe she keeps forgetting like did
I take it today and then he takes it out
like oh yeah you took it I saw you take
it I don't know yeah I don't know yeah
just a lot it's just a really weird
situation yeah this isn't really like a
relationship advice thing it's like just
a really sorrow
dilemma if I heard even like a hint of
like
[ __ ] with her pills I'm telling all
y'all yeah yeah I'd probably start
[ __ ] you know you wouldn't be putting
on the airpods you'd be like excuse me
what what did you say oh yeah I would
definitely walk in that room and be like
excuse me sir what was that joke that
you just made oh you're kidding I'm
gonna call up your girlfriend right now
explain it yeah I think that's the only
difference that's the point like you
need to remember what it was like in
high school like that you're in your 20s
yeah yeah but they're basically right
out of high school yeah well that's why
like they I think go they seek advice
from the internet right because they're
like what am I supposed to do in the
situation it's like adults need to tell
you that this is really [ __ ] serious
potentially maybe it's nothing the
holidays can create even more waste than
usual each year Americans throw away 25
more trash from Thanksgiving to New
Year's well what if we told you there
was a way to get all of your holiday
shopping done without the guilty feeling
over the waist that typically comes with
it well meat blue land the holidays are
upon us food friends family and cleaning
yeah well our loved ones can be a bit
messy see and More Mess equals more
waste but not with blue land because
blue land is on a mission to eliminate
single-use plastic by Reinventing
cleaning Essentials to be better for you
and for the planet and for this holiday
season blue land is having its best sale
of the year so you can save and shop
sustainably for your friends family and
even for yourself the idea is really
simple you just grab one of the
beautiful forever bottles mine is well
there's like different colors for each
room but there's like a pink one there's
a blue one that I use for the like the
mirror the glass products the blue a
pink one for the bathroom a yellow one
for the countertops in the kitchen
anyway you fill it with warm water and
then you drop in a tablet and then you
get to cleaning and refills start at two
dollars then you don't have to buy any
new plastic bottle every time you run
out you can just get another tablet and
it's two dollars plus the hot water in
your sink you can even set up a
subscription or you can buy in bulks you
never run out of the products that you
use the most from cleaning sprays to
hand soap to toilet cleaner and laundry
tablets all blue land products are made
with ingredients that you can feel
really good about try their cleanest kit
which has everything you need to get
started in signature scent such as Iris
Agave fresh lemon and Eucalyptus mint
Plus for a limited time blue lands hand
soap is getting a festive upgrade with a
beautiful chocolate box inspired gift
set with cozy scents like Evergreen
Winterberry and peppermint I love all of
my blue land products and I didn't even
know that laundry detergent could be in
tablet form but it's so convenient and
their little tins are so cute to keep
everything in I definitely like having
it around my home to take advantage of
their best sale of the year go to
blueland.com big mood you won't want to
miss this blueland.com big mood that's
blueland.com big mood
b-i-g-m-o-o-d the next one says my
fiance has changed his preferences to
directly fit into the female co-workers
of him
am I paranoid oh explain wait what he
likes everything that all the girls at
the office like all of a sudden all of a
sudden I'm all of a sudden into [ __ ]
Colts football does that make you feel
weird I'm all of a sudden into Andrew
Taylor
you [ __ ] can't score any points does
that make you feel weird
[Laughter]
all right this says context Nikki's
husband is into the culture
all right so it says please if I'm being
paranoid be blunt about it I do have a
history of paranoia simply due to [ __ ]
I've been through and sometimes I can't
tell if I'm acting out of line I'm a 30
year old female uh been with Matt 29
year old male for six years this all
started like six months ago okay you
changed your intuition's right let's go
new job after being unemployed for a
while due to mental health and starts
working with a 23 year old female named
Chrissy
he starts or he talks about her just
like he talks about all his other
employees no suspicious behavior in the
beginning but then [ __ ] just changes
quick like he is not a dog person at all
and has expressed multiple times that he
never wanted one but all of a sudden out
of the blue he quote needed a dog
yeah and was constantly looking up
photos of dogs or watching tick tocks of
dogs and lo and behold we now have a dog
what the connection there is that
Chrissy brings her three dogs to work
every day and only posts on social media
about how much of a dog mom she is and
how she can't trust anyone who doesn't
like dogs or can't be with anyone who
doesn't like or have slash yep
second thing Matt doesn't drink often
and when he does he is strictly a
whiskey Drinker he hates anything
pumpkin flavored and hates beer he all
of a sudden started liking some pumpkin
beer a pumpkin head beer every single
weekend this was shortly following uh
Chrissy posting on Facebook about how
being upset because she ran out of
pumpkin head and had to drink a
different beer or whatever I only know
he's like you he's like the guy from you
yeah he's [ __ ] creeping me out right
now
yeah but they started dating when she
was 24. yeah six years she's pulling a
Leo but like a you version of Leo yeah
how is she like telling this up and be
like yeah I need advice
young girls I can't [ __ ] Let It Go
man too many red flags I only know her
post because she added me on Facebook
some months ago so I know that she likes
pumpkin heads and I wonder if he had an
issue with this he has started working
late um
his buddy George is always there which I
know for a fact but so is Chrissy he
also talked to his other buddy about
Chrissy on more than one occasion in my
presence and it's all become rather
infuriating on my end because I'm tired
of constantly hearing her name and I'm
tired of constantly piecing [ __ ]
together that directly connects his
behavior to his way of living so I
questioned him about it I asked why is
he always talking about her why he got a
dog after meeting her and finding out
she loves dogs to the highest degree and
why he all of a sudden started drinking
her favorite beer and flavor when he
absolutely hated it up until a month ago
he says I'm making something out of
nothing and that he has no choice
you're crazy he says I'm being paranoid
but hasn't elaborated further my friends
think I'm being ridiculous because he is
quote allowed to have female friends
wait her friends oh it's not just no a
female friend it's like this this is
[ __ ] gross Behavior this is stalker
[ __ ] [ __ ] you need new friends [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] she's got any friends
yikes I'm arguing the fact that he has
Twisted his life to go with her
preferences since meeting her which
seems more than you normally yeah just
slightly yeah so just like oh I I hang
out with this girl sometimes after work
or whatever it's like I'm altering my
preferences yes personality is morphing
into like what he thinks she would like
yeah he's setting himself up to discard
this first girl and what's so funny is
she's probably not even into him at all
exactly yeah his girl's just living her
life like yeah I got a dog and I drink
beer or whatever and this guy's like I
have a dog now yeah I also drink beer
creepy weird yikes yeah she needs to
dump this dude unfortunately after six
years he needs to get yes yeah I think
also after that long and not like
further committing I don't know that's
me yeah
and they're 30 now so what's happening
and these are like it took five years
for us to get married and I'm like bro
that was not a good idea yeah
big changes from a guy who didn't want
any dogs so all of a sudden I want a dog
yeah or doesn't like hate spear yeah I
only drink whiskey whiskey snob that's
sexual people who drink beer yeah of
course yeah so we all agree with this
dude's trying to absolutely yeah [ __ ]
yeah let's try to be Devil's Advocate
though because unfortunately I can't I
literally can't yeah what is it he's
like made her feel crazy about this
because and why are her friends hiding I
don't understand that part yeah that
part is weird so I'm like maybe she'd
even describe all of the things like
just maybe she just told her friends I'm
kind of I'm kind of weirded out by this
girl
yeah yeah they might be like because if
she said this is a lot of detail it's a
lot yeah the top comment says you don't
just go adopt a dog in a whim after
proclaiming for years that you don't
like them yeah yeah that's a [ __ ]
huge yeah uh second comment says
paranoia aside I want to ask you how the
relationship is aside from those actions
of his does he make you happy does he
respect you I honestly find paranoid to
be stronger when deep down he's unhappy
or something is actually bothering you
yeah so even if you don't have tangible
proof that he's trying to impress this
girl I do think it speaks volumes if you
find the sudden changes to be more
bothersome than anything yeah perhaps a
sudden show of effort coming as a a
result of this girl and not because of
you makes me wonder how hard he tries to
be actively involved in your interests
or interests or show effort towards your
happiness best of luck op or original
poster but don't be afraid to end things
if he's not cutting it for you anymore
yeah I think people get too scared to
leave after so long but then like sunk
and taught the time this is some weird
[ __ ] his behavior is so weird he's
obsessed with someone else yeah and then
that makes me wonder too like how they
got together
and then he was like yeah I hate dogs
too he's just like doing whatever just
to get with the girl yeah he has like no
personality of his own that's worse let
me see if catfishes people to get with
him yikes let me see if she responded to
any comments well she did say that he
was unemployed due to some mental health
issues too like I mean maybe there's
just maybe there's something that makes
him like need some validation or
acceptance or something that he didn't
actually work through during that time
like some Borderline Personality yeah
type of thing like were you kind of
stuck in someone else's Personality yeah
so the consensus is basically like this
is not okay yeah uh someone says I think
it's time for you to part ways with this
man if he doesn't shag her yet then he
most probably building he's trying yeah
I don't think he'll get it no another
person says you are not paranoid none of
these are a coincidence he's definitely
trying to get at her yeah so I think
everyone agrees it out I don't know when
I was 23 a 30 year old dude seemed
really old yeah yeah if a guy was like
changing those things I think I wouldn't
even notice because I wouldn't even be
slightly interested
she needs to let him go and it's very
unfortunate that she spent that long
with him but that's okay like not every
relationship's supposed to be forever
yeah yeah and I'm telling you I
genuinely would if I were in her shoes I
would genuinely be very skeptical of any
thing he shared with me about his
personality whether or not I was genuine
yeah where I'm like
did you do that to me yeah yeah like
what the [ __ ] I remember early on the
first relationship I ever got cheated on
with he came home he's like oh um I want
to show you the song and it was
completely different uh like the song
was like a completely different genre
than what he usually listens to yeah I'm
like all of a sudden he's into like some
sort of weird [ __ ] classical music
I'm like well where did whoa this is
weird I never heard you listening
where'd you find this oh uh just just a
friends or just a friend and it turned
out it was a girl he was cheating on me
with so it's like oh kind of weird dude
it's weird that he would like bring that
to you yeah did you share that with me
like he had his guilt yeah yeah it's
like some form of like guilt towards
like being you then it's like oh it
wasn't yeah exactly liking her it was
just me like I'm sharing this with my
girlfriend so it's just me liking it
song yeah innocent like he's trying to
normalize it yeah it was [ __ ] weird
um but yeah I would that's the [ __ ]
weirdest thing I would not be okay with
that so I'm glad that she's noticing
these yeah yeah time to go sister all
right the next one is creepy um my
girlfriend's mother tried to embarrass
me in front of her church and when it
backfired she Banned Me from stepping
foot in her house uh this person is a
male 23 years old the girlfriend is a
female 25 years old okay so it says so I
started dating my girlfriend five months
ago she's religious no sex until
marriage leave all right now having no
time for that yeah next topic all right
end of the episode sorry I'll see you
guys next week anyways um religious no
sex until mayor marriage and I'm an
atheist I was raised in a church but as
I got older I established my own views
and I just don't believe God is real oh
I know very unlucky unlikely couple I
don't fully know how it came about
either but it works for us around our
three-month Mark she wanted to meet my
mother but warned me that her mother is
much more religious than her the first
time I met her I actually went to church
and we had Sunday dinner and that's when
I reviewed to her family that I don't
believe in God and her mother became
visibly upset calling me a faker and
saying how can I Faker uh saying how
could I even go to church and be in our
house if I'm not a God-fearing man and
even accuse me of trying to tame her
daughter
uh it was very tense and um since then
her mother doesn't like me now my
girlfriend and I had an agreement where
that I would go to church with her twice
out of the month uh I did because of
course I respected her beliefs and I
know how happy me being there made her
God this person is terrible grammar yeah
I hate that even if I did not care to
hear what they were saying she likes
that I'm there well God God punished
them for not believing so they're like
you you don't get good grammar right a
week ago her mother invited me to church
with them and at their Church they have
a segment where they welcome all the
visitors and let them introduce
themselves her mother took that
opportunity to tell me to stand up and
introduce myself and let the whole
church know that I did not believe in
God
I was very embarrassed and I did not
like being called out but I stood my
ground and said I don't believe in God
I'm only here for my girlfriend and I
know how much it means for me to be here
and support her and the preacher said
quote rather it be God or love I'm happy
you're here and you're welcome anytime
you like safe to say her mother did not
like that and when we got back to her
home she kicked me out and said it was
very disrespectful for me to be there
and that I was a faker for dating her
daughter and going to church when
honestly I just enjoyed being there for
my girlfriend there's no ill intent it
doesn't bother me when she prays I've
never faked anything the wild part is
her mother is the only person in the
family who has an issue with me she
supports and understands me the same way
I do for her she's the only girl I've
ever dated that feels right for me
because there is no crazy expectations
it's just nice peaceful I know this is
going to hurt my girlfriend she cries
and prays about it
damn that sucks because like
the mom being that religious should know
you're not supposed to judge well also
you would think that she would like be
okay with well he's not a Believer now
maybe if he's just exposed to it longer
long enough like maybe he'll come around
like aren't you supposed like Christians
are supposed to like profitize or
whatever like bring people in that's why
they might be like that's what the
future was okay yeah yeah that's like
why because it doesn't make any sense
she's a faker because she has no
forgiveness she has no patience
yes like that she's not even being right
in her own face
like literally the person that you go to
and listen to every week is saying this
is okay yeah yeah you're being a [ __ ]
about it what the [ __ ] she probably
doesn't like him for some other reason
probably I feel like that's the best
strongest reason she can come up with to
manipulate her daughter into like
getting rid of this one for whatever
reason it is I feel like there has to be
she's controlling her daughter yeah in
this this because for any Christian like
I I've never met one that's not like
you'll come around like I still want you
you know like yeah come around you know
like the if you hear the word of God
you'll come around right like they all
[ __ ] think that [ __ ] they're just
just come just come every time just come
there's something else going on yeah I
know it well control issues for sure
yeah he's my only child I wonder top
comment says dude the faker is your
girlfriend's mother she didn't invite
you to church to get closer to her God
or to be in support of her father or her
daughter's beliefs she invited you to
her church to publicly embarrass and
shame you from the congregation it was a
fake invitation luckily the preacher
knows this [ __ ] and wasn't having any of
it you and your girlfriend are old
enough to speak for yourselves so I
wouldn't be taking any more [ __ ] from
the real figure here her mother yeah so
what's she doing to you we didn't talk
about this because we didn't do catch-up
episode but I have a boyfriend now yeah
yeah we didn't tell the the podcast it's
public it's official yeah
on Instagram yeah it's really weird a
hard launching yeah
revealing a man she said his name
earlier if you guys caught it yeah it's
so funny because even the people in the
comments are like let this be known put
this down in history Gina hard launched
a man
um so on the record now so I have a
boyfriend now his name is Josh and he's
a Christian which is wild because like
Antichrist Gina
you literally are The Reincarnation of
the devil yeah he can tame you yeah and
actually we have power
um we had a conversation where like we
had a very like we sat down we talked
and I was like how do you feel about me
not being religious and like it was a
very strange discussion because it was a
lot of like well I was taught that if
you're not a Christian you would go to
hell and so I thought I asked him and I
was like so do you believe that just
because I don't believe in like
Christianity and stuff do you think I'm
going to go to hell
and he was just like
I don't know because I really don't know
how everything works I just know that
I'm a Christian and help me get through
life and I asked him I was like do you
accept me for not being a Christian or
maybe like I will never convert and be a
Christian and he was like
yes because I love you and cause I want
that [ __ ]
I think that should be good with your
[ __ ] boy face
I think there's something in the Bible
that's like uh Your Love Alone will
umbrella your house or something like
that is like the umbrella like to the
household so like even if you're not
then like God is still going to whatever
so I talked to my other Christian
friends and I was like I'm not sure how
I feel about this and they're like no
what we are taught as Christians is that
even if you have someone who's not a
Christian if you pray for them they will
make it into heaven yeah and I talked to
him about this too he's like I really
don't know because he's not like a
hardcore practicing all the time
Christian yeah he didn't go to school
for this [ __ ] yeah so it kind of sat
with me kind of wrong it's like how can
I be with someone who thinks that I'm
going to go to hell yeah you know
um but then like I talked to him
I talk to my friends and they're like no
I feel like I talked to my pastor I
talked to Satan yeah I called on the
[ __ ] dark lord what did he say um and
he's like I really don't know but I know
that I love you yeah and I know that you
know like I like he's trying to figure
it out yeah like I don't know what's
gonna happen after death but all I know
is that I want to spend it with you yeah
and so like it really did sit with me
very strangely where it's like how can I
be with someone who thinks that I'm
gonna go to hell yeah but he didn't say
that no he didn't say that he didn't
also not say that he's like I really
don't know how this he just said I don't
know yeah he doesn't know so that thing
is very honest so I talked to my uh my
Christian friends my really really
practicing friends and they were like no
in Christianity it teaches you that even
if someone doesn't believe if you pray
for them they will be yeah admitted to
the Gates of Heaven because I remember
like I asked him and I asked my
girlfriends and everything I was like so
if I showed up to the gates and I said
yo Jesus what's up and I was like in
your leather and in my leather my ball
gag yeah and I'm like yo I did not you
know commit any atrocities in life I
helped people I lived the best I
possibly can and I try to be as good as
I possibly like I'm following the the
Old Testament is that good enough yeah
and like do you think that he would just
say straight up like nah dude you're not
gonna come in here like you didn't
follow the New Testament you can't come
in yeah like am I not allowed to enter
the Gates of Heaven like [ __ ] off yeah
and so my boyfriend's like I really
don't know but I do feel like you know
it'll be okay because I you know I love
you I'm gonna pray for you and that's
fine I've never dated a religious person
in my life you know so this is like
completely to me yeah
so but I I want to understand I want to
know where your mindset is at I was
raised as a Buddhist you know so this
was like really weird to me but um like
we discussed it and it like we agreed
that we have different beliefs but it
works out because all we want in life is
to be good people yeah that's all well
that's all Jesus wanted anyway yeah
exactly I think like every religion is
just basically like just be a good
person yeah yeah so this is like a
really like I kind of resonate with this
like um yeah am I gonna burn in hell
that's interesting I like that you have
that personal aspect because of going
through that because yeah I'm you're
interested in that like yeah yeah how
that works out because for Steve and I
like we both agreed like as long as your
core life principles are in alignment
like it doesn't we don't care about
disagreeing over politics or or religion
or whatever like there if the core life
principle is there then
there's we can have discussions about
why our perspectives are different on
certain topics without like a
compromising the like the love and the
foundation of like where we want our
lives to go yeah and the life we want
the general execution of what your life
looks like is still the same yeah like
you're not doing anything that he's not
doing yeah so like Josh and I sat down
we talked about it and it's like you
know what like and and he agreed to it's
like you know what it comes down to
you tried your best to be a good person
that's how you get into heaven we're
good and there's a judgment day up there
like it's not even for anyone on Earth
to judge like and that's what I was
saying with this freaking story with the
mom judging like like if you read the
Bible and like that's what you believe
like then your soul will go up to heaven
and there's a judgment day and you they
tell you whether or not you made the cut
you know like it's not really up to
anybody else well it's also not supposed
to be based on acts anyway it's like
it's it's hard if that kind of Christian
belief is typically do you believe in
Jesus and accept him as your savior and
that's what gets you into heaven is just
your faith it's not your acts it's not
what you do you don't just be a good
person to buy your way into heaven yeah
right so it's kind of like it depends on
what specifically he's believing in but
as long as he's like comfortable with
like Hey we're both just generally good
people and then like this is just my
thing and you don't have it and I'm okay
with that and that seems fine yeah what
do you think you would do if you were in
the situation that this guy is in like
if Josh's mom was was feeling strongly
about your lack of religious practices
and Josh was like torn up about it like
how do you think you guys would handle
it so I'm very flexible with my like
religious whatever [ __ ] because I
I'm not I'm not a religious person you
know
um like one of my ex-boyfriends back
then he was like it would really mean a
lot to me if he went to church with me
I'm like cool I'll go to church with you
I was raised as a Buddhist
um but I don't practice but if it's
important to you then yeah I'll go with
you you know
um so I did go to church and I was like
it's not really my thing but it was kind
of cool because I connected with the
people there was [ __ ] dope
um I'm very flexible if you want me to
do this and this whatever when it comes
to religion because it's important to
you I'm okay with that because it's not
that important yeah I think that's great
if you had to fake it to keep him would
you do that yeah that's fine because
religion to me is not important
and if I had to kind of fake it I'd be
like yeah yeah I'll go to church with
you that's fine
um if he was like you need to get
baptized [ __ ] it I don't care like I
don't I don't really give a [ __ ] because
it doesn't really matter to me I'm not
like a hard religious person where I'm
like no I can't do that that goes
against my beliefs like I'm not the
person at all I don't really give a [ __ ]
do you feel like it's lying
um probably like I it would probably
feel like it is lying like if you ever
found out like oh you're not really a
Believer I would probably feel bad about
that like would you tell him that though
yeah like hey I'll get baptized for you
if it means a lot to you but you know
like I it doesn't mean anything to me
right now yeah like right now you know
maybe it will in the future but I don't
know I think because I don't want to lie
about that in my relationship because
that's how important it is I'm not gonna
lie and be like oh my God yes I'll get
baptized because I love you like I I or
because you know I believe it doesn't
mean anything if you don't believe it
yeah pointless I think I would be very
open about it be like hey
this isn't really what I believe in but
if it's important exactly yeah that I
get baptized sure I'll do it I may not
believe it just so he knows like the
context in the way yeah because you're
like some hardcore believer but just
because like hey you're doing this for
me yes it means a lot to me and doesn't
mean that much to you yeah just at least
so no one's getting like swindled yeah
yeah like I don't think he would ask you
to do that though because then that
wouldn't mean anything yeah exactly it's
not an actual baptism yeah I'm not gonna
pretend to be like the Judaism like they
gotta get circumcised to like convert or
whatever so it's like you know even if
it doesn't mean anything you still have
to get your your penis cut a little bit
yeah that's different from Christianity
for sure I think I'll be open about it
and be like or I'll be honest about it
and be like hey this doesn't really
I don't get it I don't believe it but if
it's important to you I'll do it [ __ ]
whatever dunk me in a bathtub yeah
whatever you know but it's difficult
though because in some Churches they're
like you need to be like on the same
page with your spouse otherwise your
household is gonna fall so like they
there are certain like so you go to
classes yeah religious sects where
they're like sex and if it if it's like
to the point where he's like oh I'm
sorry it doesn't like you're not we
can't be together yeah if you're not
really believe or a Believer then we
can't be together then you're not on the
same page yeah this is relation
YouTube's not going to work out I'm not
going to force it yeah right yeah but if
you can accept that hey I'm doing this
for you yeah to make you happy cool
we'll work out but it's that's what it
sounds like yeah yeah it's that much of
a problem um it's not gonna work out and
I'm okay with that yeah you should be
with someone who's very religious and
believes because it's that yeah exactly
yeah
that's with anything in life core values
yeah exactly like yeah if the core like
the non-negotiables aren't there then
it's not gonna work but if you guys have
the non-negotiables and Alignment then
everything else is just kind of like oh
yeah you can disagree and have
discussions on it but it's not a
non-negotiable yeah it can be hard to
fit everything in especially when it
comes to luggage with base there's room
for everything even if you're an
overpacker which I am and especially if
you have children with you that you're
packing like me I have a little baby
that I need to pack a whole bunch of
stuff for and Bayes is my most favorite
luggage system that I've ever owned in
my entire life I'm such a huge fan of
this brand you guys have no idea all of
my luggage is base I have two check-ins
I have two carry-ons I have the
Weekender like literally my entire
family is just decked out in Bays we are
huge fans so base was created by actress
Shea Mitchell to make sleek and
affordable bags luggage and accessories
designed to help you travel effortlessly
while still looking fashionable FaZe has
thought of everything you could ever
want in a piece of luggage 360 degree
gliding Wheels a cushioned handle
built-in weight indicator which is my
personal favorite because like I said I
over pack so I'm constantly keeping an
eye on how much my luggage weighs and I
do not want to pay for overweight fees
so that little weight indicator is such
a lifesaver it also comes with washable
bags for your dirty clothes and all the
interior Pockets that you need to keep
organized I especially love how one of
the Interior pockets is actually
completely waterproof so you can take a
dip in your Beach vacation right before
hopping on the plane and throw your wet
bathing suit in there and you don't have
to worry about it stinking up or wedding
anything else in your luggage base has
really thought of everything I love how
completely efficient the entire system
is their luggage comes in multiple sizes
and colors and for shorter trips the
Weekender bag is super functional and
even has a place to store your shoes
separately I have the mini Weekender
personally I love this bag it's my most
favorite bag to travel with it's so
stylish and it's so spacious even the
mini one it's amazing I love it every
piece is made to look better with miles
so you don't have to worry about it in
cargo or overhead and Bayes has over 30
000 5 Star reviews whether you're
packing for a quick trip or looking to
Breeze through the security line base
has your personal items covered right
now base is offering our listeners 15
off your first purchase by visiting
basetravel.com big mood go to
basetravel.com big mood for 15 off your
first purchase that's
b-e-i-s travel.com
big mood it's okay
oh you want him in it we're gonna have a
question for we're gonna bring Casey in
for Gina's question this was the
previous the first okay okay
so now that we
all right case
um say that you were sitting in the
kitchen here and you heard me discussing
with the girls I'm like yeah
um I've been you know I [ __ ] with my
boyfriend's um condoms I poked a hole
through it and then you hear me do
nothing else
that's kind of [ __ ] up yeah we just
kind of chuckle and then move on and
then we move on yeah would you go tell
my boyfriend because you know Josh yeah
here yeah I think I would
what would you say what do you plan of
action how would you go about doing that
like would you have thought she was
joking or like
it would feel kind of real I guess so
after say that after I said that Tiff
was like oh dude that's really [ __ ] up
man what the [ __ ] Nikki's like yeah dude
that's not cool um anyway so [ __ ]
Keeping Up with the Kardashians is on TV
let's watch it would you like it's kind
of like iffy oh you know yeah uh I would
definitely talk to Tiff first I would
say I would I wouldn't I don't know if
you go to Josh directly I would go to
Tiff person but hey I overheard a
conversation you had with the girls and
you know is Gina really yeah was that
was that a joke was that real and then
and then I guess Tiff's like oh then I
would totally judge you if you were like
oh yeah wasn't it so funny yeah right
yeah what yeah no no it was um
you know Gina
she's a little bit crazy but I don't I
don't think she's really good I don't
think she would do that oh so so Tiff
doesn't know it's but she's like kind of
not super I know what she came down
we're making it's not clear you still
feel uncomfortable then what do you do
yeah then what you're gonna go tell Josh
you tell me to go talk to Gina do you go
tell Josh like what do you
I do know Gina more than I know Josh I'm
more familiar with Gina yeah would you
talk to Gina all these are options and
Gina's like this is so we would never do
that right yeah I would say
I would say I talked to Gina then but
what if G you don't really trust you
know you're not that close with her
then I talked to Josh yeah I know these
are all okay so it's not a really
accurate analogy because so in this
scenario it's like
the girl overheard her boyfriend and his
like college best friends and they're
all like 21 to 23 years old joking
around and like out of nowhere with one
of the friends is like oh yeah I mess
with my girlfriend's birth control pills
and they're like oh dude that's [ __ ]
up and then they just like moved on
and so the girlfriend doesn't know any
of the guys and only knows her boyfriend
that's really different though because
that messes with hormones yeah he
doesn't know the girlfriend either but
like it she overheard this thing and it
didn't sound it sounded like they just
were joking about it and moved on yeah
so do you and also there's like a
history that she know that the
girlfriend knows that her boyfriend
would cover up for this guy who said he
was messing with his girlfriend's pills
in the past
for a bigger [ __ ] boy in the past for
being a [ __ ] boy yeah yeah but so this
guy's a [ __ ] boy so then what like I was
like well then why would he want to get
his girlfriend pregnant like what would
that like what's the end game there if
you think of any guy that would like
want to get a girlfriend genuine against
her will yeah no see that's why I'm like
it kind of sounds like maybe it was a
joke that got misconstrued that I would
want to clarify that it was actually
real that this guy was actually [ __ ]
with his girlfriend's pills because to
me it sounds like
it was something like oh how are you
gonna keep her and he's like I don't
know mess with her pills or something
and they're like oh that's [ __ ] up and
then they move on and like so she didn't
hear the whole conversation and then I I
don't know I mean it is a dangerous
thing if he really is [ __ ] with her
pills yeah and then I you would want to
tell the girlfriend but like how many
guys would do that at 23 years old like
what yeah
especially if this guy's a [ __ ] boy like
he would want to [ __ ] other girls the
guy's mentality at that age for sure is
gonna lean towards like I want to you
know find more [ __ ] more yeah he's good
you don't think there's somewhere you're
not trolling down one [ __ ] and having a
kid at age 21 that is definitely not the
mindset of most
insecure person has a commitment issues
and and then this chick is like
beautiful the way she she describes her
literally sure he's reaching up yeah to
lock her down even if he's not gonna
stay with her he'll cheat on her but do
you think he would pop a baby in there
just so he can have his [ __ ] baby
mama and control her that's a very scary
person then yeah exactly yeah but that's
like I don't know it's all context I'd
have to really make sure that that was
the conversation that was it sounds like
a bad joke exactly his friends were like
okay
yeah they're like that was um not funny
but we're not gonna [ __ ] tell you
that yeah
anyways so whatever yeah I do like your
initial answer I was like uh I think I
would probably tell Josh because that's
what I would want from my girlfriend so
I heard it yeah you know yeah because I
don't want to go the other thing is the
fact that this girl just isn't really
close with the girlfriend yeah
times yeah sometimes yeah
what I yeah I feel like they're closer
than she is with the girl from the way
it was described also I feel like a guy
would listen to another guy saying like
yo bro I [ __ ] heard this [ __ ] about
this chick being crazy like the other
guy would be like oh for real and then
but like a girl saying like I heard your
boyfriend [ __ ] singing this [ __ ] up
[ __ ] she'd be like who the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] you know like why are you getting
in my [ __ ] relationship because it's
very uncommon for a guy to want to lock
a ball down by like getting her pregnant
yeah and then also how does he mess with
the pills like because you can tell if a
pill's been popped out of the foil like
so what would you even do to it yeah
exactly what it what was it just sounds
like a bad joke like honestly like but I
don't know like it's really [ __ ] up if
it's true but it how the mechanics of it
doesn't matter to me and the legis yeah
just him being 21 and 23 it just sounds
like a stupid thing that he said like
offhanded yeah but I don't know I would
pay to be the one that brushed it off
and like didn't say anything and then he
really is messing with her pills I just
don't see how that how does he do that
yeah it doesn't make sense like how does
it even work all right good we got a
case in here thanks guys love you man
thanks for telling Josh I want babies
I'm glad that you said that you would
immediately tell Josh and also be like I
would talk to Tiff yeah holes and
condoms is way easier to do than messing
with birth control yeah for sure all
right uh next one says
boyfriend's prank injured me and I can't
go to work or school oh
the boyfriend is 23 years old uh the
girlfriend is 22. it says a lot of my
classes were online this year but as of
the semester I was going in person I've
known my boyfriend Evan going back a few
years enough to be comfortable
you'd have to be comfortable with
cracking jokes and a humorous
relationship our parents were friends
too but we started dating in college a
couple of weeks ago we had our first
time the reason I'm writing this is
because of what happened on our second
of having sex I think so okay
a couple days ago
20 is 23. I'm sorry she is 23 she's 22.
okay a couple days ago he asked if I
could do these splits after getting
undressed because he knew that I used to
dance but when I told him that it's been
a few years since I've actually
stretched he said it was fine however
after I tried and was quite far uh from
touching the ground he jokingly came
over and tried to encourage me while
pushing me down oh my God my back leg
even after I told him to stop what the
[ __ ] nope no that's not okay
ow what the [ __ ] the only reason he
stopped was because I screamed after he
pushed me too far and I couldn't even
stand up on my own without it burning
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this dude
yeah that's abuse when I told him to
call an ambulance he said I was quote
overreacting in that quote I should know
how he likes to joke around because what
they do it too no this guy sucks I hate
this guy but never pass the point of
someone telling me to stop or something
that could hurt someone exactly he
literally wanted me to land the ground
until quote it passed so that we can
continue but as it kept hurting continue
having sex I think so oh my God yeah I
don't like this guy at all it makes me
kind of sick to my stomach yeah God but
as it kept hurting and he finally called
an ambulance he did it with an attitude
and was pissed when they came he's
terrible wow I hope this guy [ __ ] die
he belongs in the dumpster damn I'm not
here to ask whether I should break it up
with him or not this was our second time
and the first and last red flag like in
bed thank you he pranked me in the past
in some other fun ways but uh this was
the first one ignored me saying Stop and
I'll even consider it to be a prank at
all how he keeps referring to it as that
it was a prank I couldn't even put my
pants on after the or before the
ambulance came what's the gotcha yeah
gotcha you can't do the splits and you
got injured instead yeah what the [ __ ]
uh you got pranked bro I couldn't even
put my pants on before the ambulance
came and was embarrassed the whole time
under a blanket while he sat there
pissed at me uh when I got to the
hospital he's projecting he's pissed
with himself yeah
when I got to the hospital they told me
that I had torn muscle tissue that would
require surgery to repair and as a
result I'm going to miss work for an
extended amount of time to let it rest
before eventual rehab oh my God
this [ __ ]
I have a full-time job and about a week
a kneecap on this guy I have a full-time
job and about a week at PTO and because
I'll be gone longer I'll be taking an
Loa of absence and won't be able to go
on vacation that's already paid for
although I'm hoping she missed her
vacation [ __ ] this guy he better
reimburse her for all this WOW although
the ambulance the vacation this works
exactly I would be suing this [ __ ] yeah
it probably has nothing but his parents
damn somebody God my question is my
parents don't want to help me press
charges because they're friends with
Evan's parents oh I hate I forgot that
part but that's her choice I still want
to press because I'm glad she wants to I
still want to press charges because he's
also started talking [ __ ] about me
online oh my God about how I quote
overreacted to his quote prank a doctor
says you need surgery that's not enough
surgery bro what this guy's delusional
yeah
because he feels so guilty after friends
found out well guess what race is he's
white what
I believe you can say that yes but my
parents don't want me to and said I
don't have to I don't have a case
anyways I don't think that's true wait
that's not true excuse me I don't think
so no why do the parents not have her
back I don't understand they have their
friends back they have their reputation
in mind that's why I think they're white
I don't think that's true but I want to
ask do I have grounds to sue him and how
should I manage the friends that he's
been he's trying to win over to his side
when I can't go see them freely like I
can oh I hope there's lawyers in the
comments please oh yeah didn't that one
coach get sued because yeah like there
was a cheerleading coach yeah I got like
five years because he was like pressing
down like when they were trying to do
the splits and like telling her to go
further when she's like like girls like
groin so same thing yeah same [ __ ]
totally unprofessional I don't remember
he got sued yeah something I hope she
sues the [ __ ] out of him and his parents
and ruin their goddamn lives top comment
says hold on let me get this straight
his prank resulted in you needing
surgery and he still thinks you're
overreacting yeah you can't even cop up
and that's the most infuriating yeah he
can't even take accountability there's
holy [ __ ] I'm so sorry like that's that
was way too far I [ __ ] up I I crossed
the line like can't even say that and
then and then it's going further and
doubling down and like talking [ __ ]
being like what a [ __ ] all because
Saxony wants to get off dude what the
[ __ ] uh second comment says your parents
are [ __ ] terrible yeah you'll [ __ ]
her parents oh my God third comment says
I imagine that would be grounds for
suing he kept pushing your body's limits
despite you telling him to stop and
enjoy violation he seriously hurt you
between that and thought that it still
could be considered sexual assault
because he's like I think it's sexual
yeah yeah uh between that and the fact
that this has caused you to miss work
I'd be more surprised if you didn't have
a case and honestly there's nothing you
can tell your friends but the truth if
there are on his side they're crappy
friends and you're better off without
them anyways oh God I hope she sues you
for everything that he has what a piece
of [ __ ] shame that's insane you can
force someone to do splits and she
missed her vacation yeah and work she
has literal monetary damages from this
and then her friends
and emotional damage what's going on
with the friends again what was the
friend's part he's trying to win them
over like yeah talk [ __ ] about her to
them but it didn't say what the friend's
reactions were okay yeah oh my God I
hope they cure her girl she should be
posting like the [ __ ] bills the
evidence yeah the medical bit be like
this is just a prank I'm just making up
having surgery and it's not like she
could force herself to do the splits
farther like someone had to push her
that way over the muscles to tear it's
not like that story could be made up
right
you know I sue him take him for
everything that he has [ __ ] your
appearance punch him in the Goddamn face
and leave sue your own parents yeah
the only hard part about it is how much
lawyers cost Jesus Christ there's
probably a lawyer that would take that
case and probably take a cut after like
they'll take a cut with of the winnings
once you win yeah yeah so sue the [ __ ]
out of them [ __ ] your parents yeah I'm
I'm sorry I hope you recover and I hope
that guy dang all of these here dump
your to the streets
I know seriously all right well that's
the end of our episode thanks for
watching you guys thank you leave
comments Below on what you guys think
about these relationship advice topics
that we went through what do you guys
think that they should do uh check out
our sponsors in the description box
follow like subscribe we love you see
you guys next week be good don't let
strangers love you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]